in our ion money we're looking at some
of the most costly mistakes people make
with their finances on average college
students who graduated in 2018 Oh more
than 29,000 dollars in loans
ouch last year we spoke to Megan combs
the 32 year old has been struggling to
pay debt paid down her student loan debt
for undergrad and grad school we
recently checked back in to see how
she's doing financially around this time
last year I owed about 66,000 in student
loans my payments were around $900 and I
was taking a look at my budget and my
biggest line item was my rent I was
renting a one-bedroom apartment and so I
decided to purchase a two-bedroom condo
instead and rent out the second bedroom
the condos mortgage is 10:50 so my
roommate pays seven hundred and I paid
three hundred fifty dollars a month I
also got a very significant raise that I
asked for a seventeen percent raise
right now my balance is at fifty nine
thousand yeah my payments are going to
actually now really think about it more
than double my timeline for paying off
my student loans this time last year was
around ten years and now with my living
situation in my raise all of that allows
me to pay them off in four years that is
only if I don't get another raise so it
could be I'm shooting for three years
Megan's doing really well CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger joins
us she writes about the impact of
college debt and more in her book the
dumb thing smart people do with their
money thirteen ways to write your
financial wrongs and it is out today and
paperback Jill hey good morning so when
we're looking at college which is that
daunting thing that faces every family
with children I have one still going
through this process
what do you prioritize I think we have
to prioritize the family and here's the
problem so often we're prioritizing the
student right you say oh wherever the
kid can go is great but this is a family
conversation that needs to happen and
you can see that the decision that
Meghan made
years ago is now following her
throughout her adult life so the first
thing is to have conversations with your
kids understanding where the options lie
and what's best for the whole family not
just the kid so we don't want parents
delaying their retirement we want them
to put their retirement first so you
want to think possibly you're gonna tell
Junior I know you like that big private
school but I think what we want to do is
say here are the options for the family
you can go closer to home or you can go
to a place where you can get a
scholarship but this is as a family what
we can do these conversations best had
around the junior high school year I
grew up in a family where parents never
discuss money because they said it was
impolite you said we should have a new
way of thinking about that
well I think that we want to have not
clear transparency you don't want to
actually make your kids feel your own
money anxiety but we want to have open
conversations that are direct and if you
can do that you can frame it in a way
that is really smart so look here's the
family here's what we can do here's what
your grandparents can kick in here's
what we expect you to kick in but as a
family we have to be on solid financial
footing just remember this if you don't
talk about it with your kids you run the
risk that you'd to make a decision that
puts them at risk because who's gonna
take care of you if you get older and
you can't take care also talk in the
book about failing to protect your
identity we're all guilty of that you
say or a lot of us are guilty of it yeah
because it's so boring like I can see
your eyes glazing over right now just
said protect your rights and I've been
with it right so it's what we want to do
is say of course you want to change your
password and of course you want to make
sure you have two-factor authentication
but you need to talk to the people who
are most at risk which according to
security experts is the very young and
the very old and that means no
oversharing unsocial for the
grandparents and the kids it means
making people aware that these are
problems that will not just cost you
money because sometimes they'll cost you
money but it's time and we don't want
you spending your time worrying about
that you also talk about insurance in
the book what should we know about
buying insurance what I think is really
important is that when people ask me
about life insurance for example they'll
say so everyone needs life insurance and
it's not everybody but what you need to
know is that if something has
in your life that ends your life early
will there be a financial impact on
someone else your kids your spouse your
parents maybe you're supporting your
parents you need to run the numbers
there's lots of calculators out there
and you want to stick to the simplest
solution when it comes to insurance that
is term life insurance you buy it for
the period of time where you need
coverage it goes away after that when
your burden is relieved
so again insurance really important but
not every single person needs it good
even dumb people can do smart that's our
next book thank you the dumb things
smart people do with their money is out
in paper deck today lots of good advice
you